all right let us waste no time because
we have such an agenda here at the start
of today's show updated numbers for
Democrats and Republicans in the House
and Senate in what now are midterm
elections that are just about six weeks
away numbers continue to improve for
Democrats in both the House and Senate
although Democrats are still not favored
to win in the house let's look at the
numbers in the 538 forecast for the
Senate 2022
it is now a 71 chance that Democrats
will win and only a 29 chance that
Republicans will win the most likely
outcomes are Democrats maintaining a
50-50 majority because Kamala Harris
would be the tie-breaking vote Or
democrats having a 51-49 Advantage the
way that these numbers have changed over
the last several months is directly in
the favor of Democrats as you can see if
you're looking at the screen at the
beginning of June Democrats had about a
40 percent chance of holding the Senate
that has climbed steadily to a new high
of 71 now things that happen 29 of the
sorry things that are 29 likely to
happen
happened 29 out of every hundred times
so that doesn't mean that there is any
guarantee here but right now the most
mathematically likely scenario is
Democrats holding the Senate either 50
50 or 51 to 49. now over in the house
the numbers are not looking as good for
Democrats but the numbers are closing in
on basically a two to one likelihood of
Republicans taking the house which is
far worse for Republicans than it has
been at any previous point during this
election cycle
28 chance for Democrats and again if we
look at how those numbers have shifted
over time you will see that what was at
one point a 14 chance for Democrats at
one point a 12 chance for Democrats has
now surged all the way up to a 28 chance
again the most likely outcome is still
that Republicans will take control of
the house but the likelihood of that has
declined steadily for a period of June
July August three and a half months
three and a half months as we've said
before
if at this same rate the numbers
continue to improve for Democrats by
election day it would be close to 50 50.
we don't know that that's going to
happen but that's the way the numbers
look today and the important thing is
everyone must vote do not concede any
seat fight for everything
Donald Trump completely face planted and
humiliated himself in a disastrous new
interview from yesterday with right wing
radio host Hugh Hewitt let's look at a
couple moments here on a Hugh Hewitt's
program Donald Trump tried to claim that
it's very common to send an alternate
slate of electors to claim oh give our
state's electoral votes to the guy who
lost the truth is it's not common but
Trump says it as if he's telling the
truth because he lies every second they
are attempting I think to indict people
for plans to select alternative electors
on one sec have you received the target
letter Mr President no I haven't at all
and frankly when you look at alternate
slates that way that's been done for
decades and decades many many years now
that's a lie what has been done for
decades and decades is that
you have people identified and the
people are aware okay
if Biden wins you would be you would be
a Biden elector
other people are told if Trump wins you
would be a trump elector what is not
done is that Biden wins the Biden
electors are notified it's y'all because
Biden won and then Republicans start
calling random people who were not going
to be the Trump slate of electors to say
Hey what if we just show up anyway that
it is not true that that is typical
alternate slices are actually common I
wasn't involved with alternate slates
but I can tell you many people have been
for many many years doing alternate
slates in fact uh your friend Tucker
Carlson did a story on it last night
have you a standards way of you know
working elections yeah completely untrue
completely untrue Donald Trump asked
during this interview about what if the
doj indicts you and again Donald Trump
alludes to violence take a listen to
this this is incredible you know the old
saying uh prosecutor can indict a ham
sandwich if they want to I'm just asking
if there is such a prosecutor and they
indict you would that deter you from
running for president again I don't
think the people of the United States
would stand for it and as you know if a
thing like that happened I would have no
prohibition against running you know
that you've already I do and that's what
I want people to understand that would
not take you out of the Arena it would
not but I think if it happened I think
you'd have problems in this country the
likes of which perhaps we've never seen
before
whoa I don't think the people of the
United States would stand for it what
kind of problems Mr President I think
you'd have big problems big problems I
just don't think they'd stand for it
they will not they will not sit still
and stand for this ultimate of hoaxes
that is a threat
that is a threat from the former
president to unleash his own supporters
on the country
that is what that is
um one other uh clip that we're going to
take a look at here do you feel like the
Department of Justice is trying to
indict you Mr President
well there is no reason that they can
other than if they're just sick and
deranged which is always possible
because I did absolutely you've seen the
legal papers absolutely nothing wrong
and there's no reason that they can do
that and I'll tell you what I would have
said there's no way they can raid a
house either because you know it's
Fourth Amendment stuff and what they did
is yeah they everything was signed off
on everything was legal it was not an
illegal search and seizure terrible and
I don't think the people are going to
stand for it if you noticed the poll
numbers are the highest they've ever
been the people are not going to stand
for this stuff they've well so then he
goes back into that entire uh entire
thing and uh then lastly asked about the
classified documents Trump claims he
Declassified Declassified everything he
took to Mar-A-Lago except his lawyers
are not making that argument in court
because it's an absurd argument Mr Patel
said he witnessed you giving verbal
orders to declassify the papers that end
up at mar-lago do you remember making
those orders that's correct and not only
that I think it was other people also
were there but I have the absolute right
to declassify yeah and of course as
we've said before the classification
status of these documents is not
relevant to all of the crimes Trump is
being investigated for you can't just
look at a whole bunch of documents and
say declassify even William Barr
admitted that but the big highlight here
or low light is Trump threatening to
unleash his followers on the country
that was a signal you're not going to
stand for it you're going to go crazy in
the streets if they indict me very
dangerous stuff hey this is really
interesting New Hampshire Republican
Senate candidate Don balduck last month
said the election was stolen by Joe
Biden and Trump won
yesterday on Fox News balduck was
confronted with his own comments and he
denounced them and he said you know what
I did my research Biden won
take a look at this
basically against Morse the more
establishment Republican candidate
because they were basically saying that
you're so extreme that they think that
you're more beatable and one of the
things that Maggie Hassan the Senate
incumbent will say is that you are an
election denier that you deny that
President Biden won the 2020 election
and there's this from August 14th when
you had a debate watch here
I signed a letter with 120 other
generals and Admirals saying that Trump
won the election and damn it I stand by
myself wow do you stand by that today
no so you know we uh we we uh you know
live and learn right
um and I've done a lot of research on
this and I've spent the past couple of
weeks talking to Granite Staters all
over the state uh from uh you know every
party and I have come to the conclusion
and I want to be definitive on this the
election was not stolen was there fraud
yes is that a concern of granite Staters
all over the state yes there is is there
a responsibility for public servants and
elected positions to ensure that our
citizens have faith in their voting
system yes but elections have
consequences and unfortunately
President Biden is the legitimate
president of this country and he is
ruining it along with Maggie Hassan so
listen
is it good that balduck is willing to
say this well yeah it's good because
some people on Fox News might hear it
does this represent his real and true
personal belief
I have no idea because the real
interpretation of what balduck is doing
here is he realized that with New
Hampshire voters insisting that the
election was stolen and Trump actually
won isn't helping him that's
fundamentally what this is about
and so it's about political expediency
my guess is balduck never believed that
Trump actually won I think he was saying
it because he thought it would help him
and then when it became clear it wasn't
helping him he stopped saying it but
it's still nice for Fox News viewers to
hear that couple more Clips to play for
you two days ago I told you that my
pillow Mike lindell's phone was seized
by the FBI a phone is a type of machine
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines yesterday we looked
at the search warrant for pillow and all
of the things that were on the search
warrant and then today I just have a few
clips from for you of Mike pillow really
off the rails now after this FBI seizure
take a look at this here he is on Steve
bannon's show I told the FBI guy Steve I
told the FBI guys I said that you guys
are going to be on my six o'clock show
on trained speech and and they said this
corrupt investigation whatever you're
trying to do and they go Mike we're just
doing our jobs I said yeah I said the
corruption goes back to our government
yeah stop stop stop stop I want all the
FBI people out there we got
whistleblowers all over the place that
phrase is not going to save you that's
what the Waffen SS said that's what the
Gestapo said to save themselves after
1945.
oh dear they claim to be tough on crime
and yet they have no problem calling law
enforcement Nazis that's essentially
what Bannon is saying he's like oh yeah
the FBI is saying the same thing that uh
that Nazis were saying after World War
II
um one other clip here about the cell
phone well anyway then he says here it
comes he she goes well after about 25
minutes to talk and he goes Mike we have
to take your cell phone by the way this
is from a different interview with
Charlie Kirk and I go you're not getting
my cell phone I said I'd rather be
arrested I said arrest me you're not
getting my phone I don't even I don't
use a computer this is all of my this is
my by the way what do you think happens
to the phone if you get arrested if you
get arrested they take all the stuff
that's in your pockets my business is my
lindo recovery Network this is my
thousands of employees that I I said
they were like we all rely on this I
said what would you need my phone for
and you can't have my phone he goes well
we got a subpoena right here for your
phone
um signed by a judge and I'm going okay
um
um I'm gonna can I call my attorney or
one of my attorneys he goes no there he
goes he goes I said I can't call my
attorney and you think I'm gonna give
you my phone if I don't give you my
phone am I going to be arrested he said
no but we are going to take the phone I
said well then I want to call my
attorneys finally say as you call your
attorney my attorney one of my attorneys
gets down there goes Mike just give him
the phone and I said I would rather get
arrested I said everybody relies on this
yeah anyway he doesn't seem to realize
that they take your phone if you get
arrested too and then lastly pillow says
that at a trump rally this weekend he is
going to uh I don't know address
everything in some way be with the at
the at the president our real
president's rally in Ohio on Saturday
I'm going to speak there about this we
go now we have a unique opportunity
everybody to spread the word get the
word out maybe maybe Steve that just
once that the media would go
um hey Mike why why did they do this to
you uh could it be because I have all
the evidence because I want to get rid
of voting machines and electronic
computers in our elections that's what
it is we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines anyway so pillow
completely uh his brain broke as a
result of this seizure and we'll see
what is going on next week with it truly
incredible stuff Monday 9 19. it is
membership promo day
last chance get on my newsletter at
davidpackman.com to get notified Monday
of this beautiful membership special
the David packman show is a community
and viewer and listener supported
program I would love for you to sign up
at joinpakman.com you'll get the world
famous bonus show every single weekday
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show you'll get The
Daily Show hours before everybody else
gets it and you also will be invited to
the world famous members only Town Halls
the last of which we had uh about a week
and a half ago which was really great
let's hear from some people in the
audience we are going to take some calls
via Discord which you can find at
davidpackman.com
Discord every day can be good or bad on
the Discord we never know what to expect
let's start today with Dave from New
York City why not Dave welcome to the
program
hi Mr Pac-Man how are you I'm doing well
thanks
great um thank you for taking my call
this is actually my first time calling
in and I just I wasn't even sure but you
said please directly get to the question
um I noticed that
um and this this ties into my question
um you seem to have a very good amount
of sponsors on the show
um including blinkist and um some others
um I actually did try fume and it's kind
of working out for me but I wanted to
ask you if you have any advice for
people with a pattern of self-sabotage
uh uh and this has to do with the
sponsors
well well I would say because um there's
blinkist and there's privacy and there
are things that I I feel would help me
and they seem to be excellent products
you're you're a guy who sabotages
yourself is that what you're saying
yes I have a pattern of self-sabotage
and I think that one of those things is
recognizing the services that you've
recommended and not being uh proactive
enough about following up on them even
though I think that they would help me
and that ties into a general
self-sabotage issue and I was wondering
if you have any advice for people who
have chronic self-sabotage patterns well
I think the most important thing would
be to get a therapist I mean that's
really that that would be the most
important thing uh more than anything I
could say but so in what ways do you
sabotage yourself like in work and in
relationships
um not so much in relationships I've
I've um I've always felt and I know that
I'm a great partner when it comes to
relationships but
um in terms of work
yes sometimes um my current job I have a
certain level of freedom and I I kind of
show up where I want when I want
um and sometimes that leads to me not
showing up even though I need the money
um there are other issues where in terms
of I do have a therapist and I do take
medication but I'm not always I'm not
always wonderful about the consistency
of doing so and I just logged on to
YouTube and I saw that you had a video
saying taking your calls in 15 minutes
and I figured I would try yeah well
listen I appreciate the call I I want to
be careful not to get out of my Lane I
think you're doing exactly the right
things by working with a therapist and
and that is exactly what I would keep
doing but I'm sure you're exploring this
but I think figuring out why the
self-sabotage is happening would
probably be extraordinarily useful as a
first step in figuring out how to
control it
thank you do you have any book
recommendations because it sounds it
sounds like you're an Avid Reader yes on
my website go to davidpackman.com click
on recommendations hundreds of book
recommendations there by category
okay I'll look into that all right Dave
from New York City thank you so much for
the call very much appreciate it let's
go next to Meg from Seattle Meg welcome
hi David thanks for taking my call my
pleasure
um
so uh you've probably heard the uh the
phrase that there's no ethical
consumption under capitalism
um I was wondering do you agree with
that Gary
uh no I mean listen in general I don't
agree with almost any of these
overarching absolutes for such broad
statements there is no ethical
consumption under capitalism I mean
listen you can you can argue that that's
the case and you can argue that you know
they're they're hardcore free marketeers
who say the only ethical system is free
market capitalism I find it so
unproductive to argue about such
overarching broad statements like I'm
more interested in figuring out how can
we improve the economic system we have
so that it works better for more people
and raises up uh the standard of living
and gets more people health care and uh
rewarding well-compensated jobs I I just
don't know that we get there by arguing
about whether there's any ethical
consumption under capitalism to me it
really seems like a distraction
I I think that's a good point
um and I'm guessing you don't have time
to go into you know what alternate you
know uh what alternatives you know you
would uh propose to capitalism like you
said you you're more interested in you
know looking at what we can do to make
things better yeah no I mean listen Meg
the the the general Outlook I have is
that social democracy in the style of
many northern European uh countries is
the direction I would like to go I'm
okay with markets directing resources in
many areas I'm okay with there being you
know a film and television live
streaming uh Private Industry and
decisions being made by private
companies about what to produce and then
selling it to Netflix or Hulu or what
like I'm okay with that I think that
that's okay I don't need to socialize
every industry but also we need to be uh
regulating in industry significantly for
the betterment of our planet we need to
be taxing the very rich in order to fund
programs to make sure that no one drops
below a certain standard of living we
need to be taking certain industries out
of the market and that includes health
care and others you know I mean that's
my general view of how I would structure
things to improve from where we are now
absolutely I mean our economic system is
just one piece well very big piece but
of all the the systems that aren't
working
uh that are pretty broken right yes
absolutely absolutely yeah so like I'm
more interested in that than like is
there ethical consumption under
capitalism call me crazy
sure sure uh quick follow-up um yes you
know I've also heard it say that you
know that we're in like late stage
capitalism and I'll be honest I haven't
done a huge amount of research on that
specifically but do you agree do you
think we're in late stage capitalism
um I I have absolutely no idea is the
that's you know there's this whole
movement that makes that claim
um I think we just have to wait and see
and we things are sort of unprecedented
in that modern humanity is uh a tiny
fingernail on the wingspan of how long
humans have been on this planet and
countries
um the size and power of today's
superpowers are also uh basically
unprecedented and so we are in New
Territory and I don't know it could be
that this is that that we're going to
continue improving on capitalism for the
next thousand years it could be that
capitalism is 20 years from collapse I
have absolutely no idea
okay well thank you so much for taking
my call David thank you Meg important
questions which I very much appreciate
hearing from you let's go next to Lucas
from Massachusetts Lucas welcome to the
program
Lucas from Massachusetts you are muting
yourself you have to unmute yourself for
me to be able to hear you I've unmuted
you but you must unmute yourself
and last chance for Lucas from
Massachusetts you are on but you must
unmute yourself
in order for me to hear you
all right and no Lucas unfortunately
Lucas wanted to stay muted
let's go to our friend who have not
heard from for so long Eric from Cancun
Eric welcome
[Music]
um
I want to tell you why do martial arts
and I tried to apply for politics you
applied for politics what does that mean
um let me explain first of all I do
martial arts because it's a sport and I
want to keep my muscles very strong and
very agile when I do the case and also
difference also because I needed to
protect myself when it's dangerous
nothing wrong with that
okay and also that my G4 tells me that
balance between is a way to learn how to
be violent without without being
aggressive
my teacher tells me that we gotta
control our impulses and that would be a
healthy way to
to go again against those impulses that
we have we adrenals an inner monster
that you need to control because if you
respect yourself too much then you
become very weak and cowardly but if you
don't restrain at all you become a jerk
so if I understand Eric what you're
suggesting is
martial arts is a good Outlet to know
when and to what degree to use violence
but to be able to control it when it
should be controlled is that right
[Music]
um yes stand up because we gotta said
that we have our energy months but also
our inner angels and it would be to know
when to let them let the number and when
to restrain them well I think you're
making some very good points this is
what you said this is wisdom from your
Martial Arts teacher
and Canada but also with myself my
teacher hates bullies as he is not gonna
train anyone who wants to use violence
to do whatever they want I like that I
like that listen Eric how is Cancun
these days is the is the tourism
industry of flourishing currently in
Cancun
[Music]
he is gonna be the part of politics and
martial arts okay there's a show in the
kids I like which has the original cast
of Karate Kid yes and here's in the
first part Johnny Lawrence he's the
origin the guy who will call us against
the tournament it's against Daniela
Russo the one who got kicked in the face
he went to reopen Cobra Kai because he
has three rules strike first Striker and
no mercy right nobody sounds like rules
of a bully but in his context
Stratford's means to see the moment like
when you want to grab the last box of
Christy greens from the store strike
heart is to give your best effort I know
Mercy is to not give up when you have
the chance to win all right Eric from
Cancun you have said it all thank you so
much for the call my friend
and but okay
okay thank you very much there's Eric I
know Eric always has more material but
at some point we have to say that is it
let's go next to Shelley from Indiana
Shelly welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
how are you I'm doing well
um so my question is about the Trump
Administration sure a lot of times uh
during and after you would hear Trump
supporters say uh about all of his
accomplishments but when you would ask
them what are they a common response is
well I'm not going to tell you you need
to do your own research sometimes I mean
sometimes they will Shelly generally say
well look he did the economy and he cut
regulations and he dealt with all these
great you know he dealt with countries
and he fixed the Border you know they'll
just say things that aren't true that's
another possibility
well and my so my question was were
there any major accomplishments in the
Trump Administration
that
that you could actually point to well I
there's a couple of a couple things I
mean I think that the first step Act and
the Criminal Justice Reform that he did
um
contained some positive initiatives to
some degree you know it's not a reason
to elect the guy but he did kind of
stumble I think thanks to some of the
people that were around him into a
couple of uh modest improvements there I
think that Trump's tax plan
lowering the Threshold at which medical
expenses become deductible was was a
good thing you know the tax plan overall
was a disaster uh you know I mean it's
like I can find a couple little things
here and there
okay
um yeah that was it I just
um I I hear a lot from people that oh
you know people on the left they don't
they don't want to notice
accomplishments when when there's a
republican in
yeah no listen I mean I'm glad to
acknowledge accomplishments if that's
really what they are but a lot of times
it's just they're not really
accomplishments you know what what do
you think his biggest accomplishment was
you don't know of it you don't know yeah
I mean it's tough to think of them all
right Shelly things are okay in Indiana
they're not too insane
Shelly you're breaking up a little bit
but it sounded like you said not too
many Trump Flags where you are I really
appreciate the call okay
thank you all right there is Shelly from
Indiana the internet tubes must not be
super wide there which is why we were
having an issue I'm gonna take a very
quick break if you are holding
don't hang up because I'm going right
back to the phones in a moment
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
let's get back to the phones and by
phones I mean Discord davidpackman.com
Discord is the place to go let's go next
to Seth from San Diego Seth welcome
what's on your mind
hey David
um I I just wanted to ask what
um
you know I see a lot of these
conservative ads uh saying let's get
wokeness out of our military and as
someone who currently is serving the
country and this is my own personal
opinion I cannot stress that enough of
course this is my own personal opinion
is not affiliating with any of the
branches that I'm serving right now but
when they're saying that
there's like as a person who's in it I'm
like I don't see any wokeness around
here because everyone is so unfiltered
and the only thing I can think of is
sexual harassment seminars or dbaa which
means don't be in you know you know
don't be an a-hole basically
I don't know
anything it's sounding pretty woke to me
no you're of course completely right
you're completely right and honestly I
think the main wokeness allegations came
from when Mark milley was saying hey you
know in the military we should know
what's in the culture and so if critical
race theory is something that is being
studied in the culture we in the
military should at least understand what
it is it doesn't mean anything beyond we
should just understand what it is and
that's when all of the allegations of
woke General and woke military started
but as you're pointing out uh it it
doesn't really have any connection to
the reality of what's going on
exactly because again like everyone kind
of pokes fun at each other by like well
like a lot of the things they said a lot
of race a lot of racial stuff wasn't out
but definitely some sexual harassment
and we definitely have sexual harassment
seminars yeah going all the way up to
the ranks and we do have extremism in
the ranks which is very popular but
that's not necessarily A woke it's just
more like hey this is professional in
the workplace we have to be professional
in the workplace but off the clock you
can do whatever you want and that's kind
of the same thing as is the the job I'm
reservist so I work two jobs and there's
a girl that was working and she was very
unprofessional very inappropriate and I
had to say hey what you're saying is
inappropriate you can't be doing that in
the workplace I don't care what you do
outside in the workplace it's working
and I'm sorry but you have to give up a
little bit of your rights when you work
I mean right I I I yes no well it's not
about giving up rights it's about your
employer can use any legal means to
determine whether they want you working
there and so like saying we don't allow
black people to work here is not a legal
means saying we believe that's kind of
what I meant we believe the off the
clock social media statements to be a
problem that actually is legal for
employers to consider if they so choose
but that's sort of a different different
discussion let me ask you this it is
um okay do you find that most of your
fellow reservists are right-wing or
left-wing or sort of split
I would say maybe around 60 right wing
okay there's definitely hardcore
trumpers in it and that's not hiding it
yeah I would say around like the one I
know of uh quite a bit of liberal
Marines but we kind of kind of whisper
about it we're kind of a little
kind of shut our mouths about it you
know okay it's very it's it seems like
it's very conservative but there are
other people that's going to stay out of
it or they have their own opinions or
they're not that political do you think
that the left Wingers at least that you
know in the military are a little more
cautious about expressing their views
because of a concern as to how it will
be received
yes very much so I'm probably one of the
only people that can act what is
expressing their views and I have to
kind of downplay it a little bit but I'm
not like scared about it I'm not afraid
of expressing my opinions if someone
asked me politely and I'm fine to have a
discussion yeah uh but yeah there's a
lot of right Wingers but I can at least
work with them you know I can at least
tolerate them and we're we'll die for
each other literally that's what you
know that's fine I'm I'm in calm so it's
a little bit of difference yeah but
there's a lot of smart people if they
say oh Trump supporters are stupid not
entirely the case their ideas yes but as
a people in general they're just people
they just have the they just have it
switched that's really mainly what it is
all right Seth from San Diego powerful
declarations thank you
thank you so much David I appreciate the
opportunity all right there goes Seth
from San Diego let's check in next with
oh oh how about Elias from Texas Elias
welcome
hey David
hi yeah your audio is already glitchy
but what's going on did you hear me yes
I can
oh
um
it is the start of Hispanic Heritage
Month tomorrow will you teach your
daughter any Hispanic Traditions or
teach her Spanish how important is your
Hispanic identity to you hold on
Hispanic Heritage Month starts in the
middle of the month
yeah that's weird that doesn't really
mean are you sure about that usually um
it starts on the first yeah yeah
see yeah
it's start that you're completely
correct that's bizarre but you're
completely right wow Elias okay I
exclusively speak Spanish to my daughter
so the idea will be that she with with
me and with my parents she oh we only
speak Spanish to her yes
was that your only question do you
no I'm saying like do you have any like
traditions that you're also gonna like
teach her or absolutely well she's going
to be well versed in the eating of
milanesa I can assure you uh as well as
you know empanadas and all of these
different things yes there's going to be
all sorts of traditions she's going to
get the best of both worlds she'll get
the Argentinian traditions and the
Jewish tradition so you know latkes and
the entire thing pastrami you know
that's amazing yeah so so
um how how important is your Hispanic
identity to you it must be pretty
important since you're you're passing it
down to your daughter absolutely I don't
want that to be lost and you know to
some degree I mean listen
five generations from now if my
descendants remain in the United States
I think it will probably be lost
inevitably it's very hard to keep it
right indefinitely but for now I'll do
what I can
right yeah all right uh that that's
basically it thank you thank you so much
there is Elias from Texas always
important to make every effort to
pronounce people's names correctly let's
go next to let's try Roy from South
Jersey Roy what's going on
Roy from South Jersey you are on the air
can you hear me now yes I can sir
um I have in my phone a list of topics
that I'd like to discuss whenever I come
on but this is too pressing for just a
regular list yeah I went to I'm in I'm
in Florida yep uh and I went to a
supermarket and I saw something I saw a
my pillow store in the supermarket now
wait a second you are you that sounds
more like something that would happen in
Florida but you said you're in Florida
uh yeah Florida yeah oh wow no okay uh
well that's in so there's a my pillow
store inside of another store that's
interesting
I was very uh worried that they would do
a class action lawsuit against me but um
anyway
um you know I really like how you've
challenged a lot of uh grifters over the
years like Dave Rubin but uh everyone
has a price so my question to you is
um if say Bill Gates or Elon Musk or
whoever said I will pay you however much
yep name your price but I want you to go
on the air on your show in a um Tony the
Tiger uh costume and say I love kids
menus they're great what would your
price be oh that I mean that's not I
thought you were gonna say to like
become a conservative on the air for the
next decade or something like that I
mean that sounds kind of funny I would I
would do that for you know I don't know
make me an offer if that's interesting a
Tony the Tiger outfit and saying that
they're great that that I would uh I
would do for a lot less and then I would
take 90 of the money and put it back
into causes I agree with
all right thank you all right Roy I hope
uh my answers were satisfactory there is
Roy from South Jersey let's go next to
how about John from Sacramento John
welcome
hey Jamie can you hear me yes I can
so I think every David Pacman's fans
worst nightmare happened to me last time
I called in the mic didn't work I was
panicking frantically trying to get the
buttons to work nothing did so I'm
elated that it worked out I share in the
Elation with you
huh so I'm an absolute political Layman
but I had this crazy idea I wanted to
run by you just get your opinion please
so I looked at the Second Amendment
after Uvalde got really depressed I was
like man this is what can we do yep and
I thought about the first part and I
thought and thought and thought and so I
was outside the DMV and I was like
that's it what if we had a department of
militia regulation and that department
said okay we get to decide who can be in
the militia not I think uh level one you
can be Hunter so any bolt action rifle
sure here in the militia you can go get
that at your store oh you want to move
into level two well that's assault
rifles yeah you're a 25 year old in the
militia and then we just set that up
because right now Biden's uh not
fulfilling his constitutional obligation
he's gotta have that regulated militia
so I don't know what are your thoughts
on something crazy like that listen
you're thinking too rationally and
here's the reality and the the Supreme
Court has found that the second
amendment applies to in an individual
right to have a firearm so the focus on
the militias it's not actually relevant
unfortunately I mean I think it's a
great idea what you're saying I think it
should be applied just more generally to
gun safety regulations but um no if you
if you did exactly what you're
suggesting the reaction would be to
rightly say the Supreme Court already
found that there is an individual right
to a gun outside of any militia we don't
need to be regulated as militias
do you think I would push
another case of the Supreme Court if you
tried to do that and there'd be well I
guess with this course I just don't
think it would happen to be told I don't
want to bum you out John but I just
don't think it would go anywhere
well but listen you're thinking of the
right things which are we need to take
control of the situation we just have to
find a way to do it legally
all right David I appreciate you taking
my call all right there is John with a
very important question that we are
going to continue looking into let's go
next to Paul Garcia from Mexico welcome
Paul
hi David can you hear me I can hear you
fine
oh okay uh going to going back to the
Andrew Yang third party proposal yeah do
you remember it of course uh what would
you like to see what would impress you
from a third party well I would like to
see a third party that's to the left of
the democratic party but not made up of
people who are cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs
like the green party that's what I would
like to see I would like to see an
actual socially Democratic party that's
to the left of the Democratic Party
could could they be like
um
if if they're a third party God power
you know in the in the US yes I don't
know the senate or something in in the
future right could they do like uh
direct voting on on issues like you know
because he talked about General
consensus is and and stuff like that
right yeah
um so could they both pass like do you
want this or that and take about
nationally well that's not really a
question about third parties it's just a
question of how our political system
works I mean are you saying if you had
members of this imaginary third party in
the Senate is that what you're saying
yeah could could they be could they do
that bigger reform or if they were in
the Senate they would get a vote I mean
I think I might be misunderstanding your
question but wherever these third-party
candidates were elected they would be
able to vote and influence policy
whether it's the house or the senate or
if you had a governor or whatever the
case may be I I apologize if I'm
misunderstanding the question
no I I think you're getting the right
jokes I think it would be like a
constitutional change I guess my
question
yeah the the Constitutional change might
be required to get the third parties
elected the way things are going but I
have said I have clips about how third
parties could could make inroads but
that's its own complicated reality as
well yeah uh yeah thank you Paul what
part of Mexico are you in
uh Chihuahua last time I was I was here
I told you it was kind of getting chilly
yeah and you were like uh how cold is it
and I was like uh I don't know minus
five or something and you said like well
that's barely getting cold but have you
ever been in a dry cold air dry cold air
I I I guess I don't know the sensation
is completely different here in the cold
I know you you're in uh near New York
right yeah
so you you get really cold Winters yes
but I've been in the U.S in uh humid
regions and minus 17
um
Celsius yes feels like
um minus 10 here I swear well I believe
it I believe it what's the elevation
where you are do you know
uh it's around 2 000 meters two thousand
meters oh wow that's and you're are you
completely acclimated to it it feels
fine no headaches nothing
uh I I'm from a small town I Live Now in
a city here is like one 1 400 my town is
to 200 2200 so it's it's it feels the
change you feel like when you go back
and forth I bet I bet all right Paul
well thank you for the call
thank you too all right a beautiful
phone call from our friendly neighbors
to the south in Mexico where I hope to
return very very soon folks that does it
for calls today my apologies I throw
myself at the mercy of those who I was
unable to get to but I can assure you if
I have anything to say about it and I
believe I do we will take calls again
and I will speak to you next week but
we're just going to take a quick break
and then the show continues
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's get into our mailbag it's the
Friday mailbag you can email info
davidpackman.com if you have a question
comment concern anything you want to
demand a correction for occasionally we
will grab a comment from YouTube or
sometimes Facebook or sometimes a tweet
or whatever the case may be uh let's get
right into it as we often do starting
with some criticisms which is fine DL or
Patrick I don't know wrote in and says
Biden should be in jail family corrupt
over 40 years Where Have You Been maybe
you haven't been around long enough
please read all info on Biden's laptop
both dad and son should be in prison for
all their dealings with China Ukraine
and other countries they have made
Millions from money laundering I know
you know this with a question mark
this is the type of person where we just
need there's not enough time between now
and the election to talk sense into
someone like this
so my advice from a voting standpoint is
we just have to find two new voters to
cancel out this guy's vote I mean one I
guess to cancel it out but then a second
one to actually make some progress I
don't see how someone who
is in such a fantasy world that their
one contact with me is to tell me how
everything about my perspective is wrong
because it lacks the stuff from the
Biden laptop and Biden and Hunter should
be in prison that I don't think we have
the the time capacity
to just argue and change these people's
minds if you think there's some way to
fix these folks brains
let me know but I think it's much
simpler to register people to vote and
to uh cancel out their votes next
message is from Cara Cara wrote it and
said you're a effing Nazi beta boy
well I'm Jewish
so I don't know what you mean by Nazi
but my family fled the Nazis
Cara goes on there are hundreds of
millions of trumpies who will make sure
your voice is silenced on social media
as ours have been who the f are you
well if you don't even know who I am
why is it important that hundreds and
millions hundreds of millions of
trumpies silence me
if I'm so insignificant that Cara has
not heard of me I don't know why anyone
would need to waste any time silencing
me by the way it's really interesting
how the the delusions seem to spread
virally and what I mean by that is
recently Trump pulled this idea that
there's hundreds of millions of Maga
people at his last rally Trump said
something like oh there were the 75
million who voted for me plus another
150 million probably like so there so
Trump believes that there's 225 million
trumpists
um in the United States now correct me
if I'm wrong
number of adults in USA 2022
what are the number of adults
I actually can't find that anyway the
point is 225 million magats is like it's
got to be close to every adult I don't
know what percentage of the population
is under 18 but it's got to be 20 or or
more anyway as usual as is the case with
these people The Numbers Never add up
the Numbers Never add up thank you cara
I appreciate that okay Mike wrote in
again asking about these spam messages
that he's getting Mike says I've
received this message a couple of times
in response to comments made on Dave
Pacman YouTube clips question is scam or
legit
I don't use WhatsApp but I am curious
and it's one of these messages where the
user has my
a picture as their profile picture and
it says write me
I know that this is a disappointment to
some in the audience some people will
write to me and say David I was so
excited that you wanted to hear more
from me about my view on you know
Hillary Clinton or whatever that I tried
writing you on WhatsApp like you told me
I am not asking anyone to text me
or to Whatsapp me or anything
these are scammers report them to
YouTube we are doing everything we can
to get this Scourge As Trump would like
to say
off of YouTube
as far as I know no one's been scammed
so far but eventually they will ask you
for money that's the scam and at some
point I'll do an expose a bigger picture
on on the full scan but no I'm not
whatsapping anybody I'm not texting
anybody I don't want you to text or
Whatsapp me it is a scam do not fall for
it Jaden noticed an anomaly on our
a social blade page which tracks our
YouTube channel Jaden said David sir I
was looking at the social blade for your
YouTube channel and I noticed it as a
graph of your subscriber increases
I have tears in my eyes as I tell you
that it appears that the machines have
been dumping you subscribers of ten
thousand every couple weeks there are
huge gaps and irregularities that cannot
be explained please sir we need pillow
on the show so he can explain how the
machines did this yeah you know a few
people have written to me and they said
David
is there a scam going on with your
subscribers because it you get none for
days and then suddenly ten thousand in
one day let me explain
on YouTube once you get to a million
subscribers
uh the algorithm shifts into tracking
them in tens of thousands so like when
you look at our YouTube channel it'll
say
1.47 million subscribers and then it'll
go to
1.48 so it tracks them in 10 000
increments when that is the case
socialblade does the same thing so in
reality we get like 600 subscribers a
day
but it only updates now every ten
thousand no scam going on check any
channel above a million subscribers and
you will see it's the same Michael wrote
it Michael says David I sincerely want
to thank you for the public service you
do in showing the liars and hypocrites
on your show I think it's very necessary
but I can't bear to watch some of the
outrageous Clips you show so I mute the
sound and just listen to your commentary
to learn what nonsense was said you must
have a great deal of self-control to be
able to listen to Trump and the magas
day in and day out well I don't know if
this is a good thing or a bad thing I've
talked about this before
there is a desensitization that happens
when you do what I do
where because outrageous things happen
so often they start to seem less
outrageous and that's why it's good
number one to take time away from this
stuff
and number two to talk to people from
different places so when I talk to
family of mine from other countries or
even when foreign callers call in or
when I read articles about American
politics from other countries
it's always good to have sort of your
sensibilities reset because it's nuts
here this Maga right-wing authoritarian
wannabe fascist movement that is written
about here by Michael
these people are genuinely dangerous and
it's also not typical it's really not
typical and it's good to get that
perspective from other countries Daniel
wrote in about Mike pillow
and says David do you really think it's
appropriate to have Mike Lindell on your
show again after his manic episode on
Facebook it's clear Mike is unwell
inviting him on again almost seems wrong
like we're making fun of someone who
needs a doctor anyway just a thought let
me know what you think Daniel from
Indiana says don't have pillow on
because he's he's mentally ill uh I I
mean I don't know that we know that
and honestly probably like 20 of our
guests are mentally ill by some
definition I don't know I don't know
what the standard should be
it's a tough one but I'm willing to hear
from people in the audience Aaron wrote
in and uh writes in about CNN's right
turn Aaron says hi David I'm a
progressive possibly a little to your
left on some issues but I have to say
that I'm not scandalized by CNN's
decision to drop the big live moniker
even though it's very clearly a big lie
don't you agree that the term sounds
quite editorialistic for a new segment
I'm not convinced that a commitment to
more neutral language is in fact a turn
to the right no listen on the CNN right
turn it's no one thing
it's not oh we're dropping the big lie
alone
It's a combination of things including
statements made by the new CEO or
president whatever he calls himself
um the big lie thing is one Element
changes to Staffing it's a lot of
different things recent comments from
anchors I would never make the case that
just based on not using the term big lie
anymore CNN is now Fox News that
wouldn't be uh accurate it's not what I
believe but go back to the segment I did
on it and it's a much bigger picture
issue than that
Rodney wrote in about abortion and said
hello should a registered or voting
Republican be allowed to get an abortion
in the United States I get the point of
this question
if you vote against abortion being legal
by voting for elected officials who will
try to make it illegal should you be
allowed to get an abortion it is so
outside of any legal framework to deny
abortions based on how people vote that
my opinion is here's Here's my thought
Rodney okay and and I really appreciate
the message I get why you're asking the
question
it's a losing direction to go in saying
okay
make abortions illegal for Republicans
because they wanted to be we're almost
as bad in saying deny a legal medical
procedure to people right and so no I
don't think that that's a good idea at
all Gabriella wrote in about Democrats
quote winning and and she makes a good
point
Gabriella says hello sir my dad used to
tell me when I would ask who's winning
during any sports game well no one wins
until the end they're only ahead for now
I thought this might be relevant to your
recent clip on Democrats leading across
the country albeit not by enough they're
ahead for now but it's up to voters to
help them win a hundred percent correct
and this is why every time we look at
2022 polling numbers Senate forecast
house forecast I always say
this is where we are right now there are
things not yet reflected in the polls
everyone must vote everyone must vote
and I hope that you will
and uh we're starting to get down to the
wire if you have never voted before at
least Google voter registration deadline
in your state and understand when can
you register can you register same day
it's very important to know that and I
hope every single one of you votes all
right Monday 9 19.
David packman show membership special
we're going to be blowing out
memberships at rates never seen before
at a huge discount the theme is 919
that's the date if you would like to be
notified about this membership special
you need only get on my newsletter at
davidpackman.com we'll see you on the
bonus show and back here on Monday
foreign